too few books for about my people where
are our stories where is our
representation would you give us the
pleasure of reading an
exerpt yo Shira girl you be pregnant
again if I is Ray Ray is going to be a
real father this time
around thank
you let's start with the book that this
is based on it is a 2001 novel by person
Everett called AER uh where are you at
in your life when you read this book and
and what about it convinces you to go on
what I imagine was a long hardfought
journey to bring this to the big screen
I just read this I was reading this uh
book review for a different book called
interior Chinatown uh one day and uh
there it said that interior Chinatown
had a satire reminiscent of personal
ever it's eraser and I'd never heard of
eraser and I went and read the synopsis
it sounded interesting so I bought it
and then then um I had this experience
that that is really
wonderful which is that I felt like
somebody had written a novel
specifically for me I don't know if
anybody's ever felt that but it felt
like somebody had sat down to write cord
Jefferson a book and you know I have two
older brothers we have a weird sibling
Trio dnamic the way that they do in the
in the story here right and sometimes
we're Clos or sometimes are farther
apart we have a very overbearing father
figure who looms large in our life and
I'm sure will after he's gone um my
mother didn't die of Alzheimer's but my
mother died of cancer about 8 years ago
and and you know when she first got sick
it was the responsibility of my brother
who was living in our hometown to take
care of her and and take her to her
appointments and buy groceries for her
the way that Lisa took on that
responsibility in the film and then
toward the end of her life I I moved
home to take care of her so there was
just all these overlapping themes and
experiences that felt like you know I
think the key to a good adaptation is to
find
find what feels really personal for you
and find find yourself in that material
as soon as I was done with the book I I
called my manager and said I think I
found the thing that I want to direct um
I think that I I found the thing the
first movie that I want to write and the
first thing that I ever want to
direct Jeffrey I know you've said that
this is your most personal role this is
my favorite role of yours as a fan of
yours thank you uh when you got the
script did you know that cord wrote the
role with you in mind I'm always curious
from the perspective of an of an actor
finding that out if there's extra
excitement or extra pressure there and
then I mean at what point when you were
reading the script did you say oh I'm
I'm all in on this well uh cord you know
the script came through the you know the
usual suspects you know my agent sent me
the script they were very excited about
it and there was a letter attached to
the email from cord and I I actually
went back and and looked at it because I
was trying to retrace the the timeline
and he there's one sentence in sentence
in there he says um I have no plan
B and it was you know it was very very
flattering and and uh and and then I
read the script and like
cord um I I I felt a very close um close
emotional connection to the journey of
the character and it had to do um you
know similar uh to what cord described o
to um actually the the phase that I
found myself uh living within at the
time that I received in my my mother
passed from cancer about a year before I
I got the script and
uh
uh that was that left a void that uh a
year did not fill and will never be
filled but um and as well I was raised
by two women I was raised by my mother
and my aunt H who was the eldest sister
she's now 94 and I was you know
caretaker to my mother at the end of her
life and then um my aunt came up from DC
to live with me and you know there's
that strange process that we experience
and it's it's it's it's strange but it's
also wonderful in which you know the art
that we are drawn to or that is drawn to
uh to us overlaps the reality of Our
Lives Sterling um you know one thing I I
love about you as an actor is whether
it's a comedic role or a dramatic role
or a role like Cliff that is complex and
layered and multi-dimensional you you
always give every ounce of yourself to a
role and and it's what I've always
respected about you man and I I if I see
Sterling K Brown in a in a TV show or a
movie I I even if I don't know what what
what it is I'm I'm watching it because
of you um and I'm I'm curious like in
terms of finding Cliff was there a line
was there a scene was there something
that Court said to you where it just
clicked and you knew who this guy guy
was and you knew how to play him no um I
think but the the opposite is sort of
like there was an intense amount of fear
and I think that's what made me excited
and want to do it right like I don't try
to lean away from it I was like oh gosh
this character is great I don't know if
I if I can do it or what not so maybe I
should go ahead and say Yes um it's a
little bit sadistic what not but it
served me decently thus far the writing
was so good and I will say this I have
uh several members of my family who are
lgbtq who I felt were not able to live
their full truth right and an aunt in
particular who never came out directly
to her mother and father mother and
father probably knew but she never was
able to say exactly she would Al always
introduce peram Moors as my friend and
that was okay with her mom in our family
in St Louis Missouri everything was okay
as long as you didn't quote unquote put
it in their face you know what I mean
and so the there's a real kinship that I
have to those folks in my family because
they still live in St Louis Missouri
which is not New York and it's not LA
and so while there may be a greater
level of Acceptance in 2023 I would say
it's far from Full acceptance and I
think probably the thing that really
sold it for me was the last conversation
that we have when I'm talking about like
I wish I had come out to my dad um and
just to be fully known because I think
you can only have a real shot at
happiness until you are fully known and
what you see is Cliff in the midst of
sort of like how do I allow myself to
live my full truth somewhat recklessly
but always on purpose because for the
past 20 years he's had to just sort of
be a shell of himself right and so now
you see he is busting out of the seams
coloring outside of the lines until he's
able to find a new equilibrium so I
would say that last scene was the thing
that really clicked for me Erica I feel
a lot of these characters in this film
are kind of coming into their their own
and what I love about Coraline is I
think in any other film there's a meet
cute fall in love somebody's running
after someone in an airport at the end
of the movie you know and it's super
cliched but Coraline the relationship is
is so layered and complex and different
that that realness that I was talking
about is there and you know they're not
falling in love with each other maybe
they're falling in like with each other
uh you know these are relationships
older relationships reaching middleaged
relationships we don't see these on
screen you know just talk about how this
role came to you and and you know what
did you see in this character that was
personal for
you Coraline is a is
um there's a very strong Melody Jeffrey
Wright brings it naturally but also the
character monk his name is Monk and
she's playing just under those notes and
it's a delicate balance I don't have to
do much except for get out of my own way
and just be confident you know
and I say that having been 40 years in
the business that it's often hard to
remain confident and know that sometime
the the the beest hints of what you're
going to do will actually speak the
loudest that he's already done the work
on the page he's cast a
great cast who on their own would be
great but then as an ensemble
everybody's just trying to figure out I
think the the right balance but that's
what we been doing for years is learning
how to play those notes inside a very
complex composition and still remaining
strong so they can hear what you're
trying to give so that's what I did it
was a very easy gig in that way but I
think that it used muscles that I don't
get often asked to use and so therefore
it's more difficult for me and so um I
was glad to be a part of the family that
he built and the possibility of what
monk wanted because monk is looking for
something that she offers maybe a
possibility to but he is confused right
now and so you're right they may be
falling in in like but they're trying it
out and I think in a mature relationship
you try things out Leslie Agnes is the
is the matriarch of this family every
one of these children there's a little
bit of them in in her she's also
suffering from Alzheimer which I think
makes her instantly relatable to a lot
of people including myself my mother
doesn't have Alzheimer's but she does
have dementia and right now uh you know
our my siblings were all coming together
and figuring out you know extracting
ourselves from our busy lives and then
figuring out what kind of family we are
when the heart and soul of our family is
in Decline you know and I and so that's
I very much relate to what's happening
in this film and I'm curious about you
know what did you see in Agnes that
maybe made you excited because it was
personal but maybe it wasn't something
that you'd ever played before in your
career it's interesting that Sterling
said talked about
fear and I think beside having a
incredible script and words that people
really
say um I thought
about what it would be like if that were
me because part of our our job is to
memorize our lines you know and every
now and then
you walk into a room and you go why did
I come in here again what what was I oh
yeah I came in here to to get the pencil
and
so when that happens to me I go is this
the beginning of something
here um I'm a verbal person I love to
talk and is this the beginning of
something and so it was fascinating for
me to play this character because what
goes on in your head because sometimes
she's loosen and then sometimes she
isn't and that's kind of scary and so I
wanted to play this role
because we hear about Alzheimer's now
more than we ever did when I was growing
up you just got old but people are
living longer and you know there's a
whole lot going on so I I wanted to to
explore uh this character is a film
about a family you're all in Boston
together I feel like at some point
you're going to look at your cast and
you're going to say they're a family now
when did that happen what was that
like I just felt nothing but love for
the people here to my left and as soon
as they were on set it felt like this
like this what you're seeing right now
is how it was every day and I think that
you know I hope that that love is in the
film that's sort of ort of like that
that because that's this kind of that's
the kind of environment that that it was
and so um I didn't have to do much
honestly it was like these people just
showed up and and it was like this it
was like they were a family already and
I just want to congratulate you and
thank you uh for making this because it
is a really special film and ladies and
gentlemen the film is named American
fiction if it means something to you if
you liked it if you had fun and you want
to talk about it then talk about it to
your friends and your family it comes
out in theaters soon in New York early
January it's all around the United
States thank you so much for coming out
today Jeffrey Wright Sterling K Brown
Erica Alexander Leslie ugam my name is
Eric Davis thank you very
much